bon un immeuble apparemment comme les
autres dans les quartiers sud de
marseille comme les autres pas tout à
fait camille n'a pas besoin d'enfiler
son manteau pour aller à l'école
elle habite au deuxième étage
la maternelle est situé au huitième elle
rencontre ses amis dans l'ascenseur elle
monte avec elle
les colts un peu sa famille une femme
d'ailleurs il ya une règle est assez
drôle c'est que camille quand on lui a
demandé en classe très elle a dit
j'habite une petite section de l'école
sur place mais aussi des commerces un
gymnase un supermarché et même un hôtel
restaurant
c'est le concept de village vertical
autonome imaginé par l'architecte
urbaniste le corbusier pour reloger les
sinistrés de la guerre c'est la première
fois que le grand architecte le
corbusier réalise enfin son rêve
d'habitat rationnel dans sa bio holding
au de 17 étages et le cap et
retrouveront tout ce qui est
indispensable à la vie de chaque jour
depuis le café du matin jusqu'au cinéma
du soir le corbusier à marseille
c'est peut-être la première pierre de la
cité de l'avenir
55 ans après la cité radieuse n'a jamais
aussi bien porté son nom
pas tellement pour son béton brut un peu
défraîchi mais plutôt grâce à ses
habitants suzanne habite là depuis
l'inauguration aujourd'hui encore elle
reste sous le charme des trouvailles de
l'architecte ration de cuisine et en
même temps c'est un accroche casseroles
dont on ne cherche pas la petite pointe
pour accroc mais pour elle la réussite
et surtout humaine en 1952 un problème
de chauffage la rapproche une première
fois de tous ses voisins
le début d'une aventure de réunir pour
grogner contre le chauffage pourquoi on
ne pourrait pas se réunir pour faire
autre chose et on a créé l'association
le 14 janvier 53 et cetera pied c'est
faux vous connaître et la bibliothèque
une salle de loisirs pour les jeunes une
salle de danse une chorale de la musique
de chambre
mais tout le monde était prenez la
responsabilité de son club c'était que
de choses extraordinaires sa vie
associative
ces commerces sont entrés unique pour
provoquer les rencontres mais aussi son
incroyable toit-terrasse façon paquebot
lieu de récréation rêvée pour les
enfants c'est un peu tout cela qui a
poussé la fondation le corbusier a
demandé l'inscription de la cité
radieuse au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
c'est un monument historique comme tous
les monuments historiques
il coûte cher et peut-être que le
classement au patrimoine mondial ça
pourrait aider les habitants à gérer ce
team up
un classement qui aurait pu agrémenter
l'arbre de noël mais qui n'est pas
espéré avant juin 2008
il récompense serait peut être moins un
chef d'oeuvre d'architecturé une
évidente réussite sociale
je